[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti Grazie mille
dell'accoglienza ho fatto bene a venire
Grazie a te
gentili mi è difficile come attore
parlare del mio lavoro e della
creatività Di solito noi che recitiamo
preferiamo agire Quindi questa sera per
il tema del vuoto di come colmare il
vuoto
tratterò di come il vuoto sia una
mancanza propedeutica la creatività di
come il vuoto del pubblico sia un
momento di
allontanamento da quello che il palco è
una fase
fondamentale per arrivare alla
creatività e faremo anche un pezzo dove
il teatro e il vuoto verrà colmato dalla
vostra immaginazione e tutto questo
insieme farà Spero vivere un momento
bello di teatro
il vuoto in mancanza
cosa ci spinge a salire su un palco a
molti di noi che facciamo i comici gli
attori senz'altro C'è una mancanza di
tipo affettivo ma ora qua non voglio
parlare dei traumi soprattutto non dei
miei ma viene veramente colmato dal
momento in cui nel momento in cui si
incontra il pubblico e arriva un affetto
questo non vuole essere una leccata al
pubblico ma per raccontare veramente
quello che succede anch'io venendo qua
dovendo preparare questo speech ero
emozionato tanto
e devo dire che non c'è momento più
bello di quando si fa una serata e
questa va bene poter poi stare nella
città il giorno dopo a incontrare le
persone il vuoto per noi importante
anche
perché viene da pensare Allora visto che
così bello recitare essere col pubblico
perché uno non lo fa 24 ore su 24 Ecco
questo è quello che propongono alcuni
reality e social Ma lì nella performance
manca qualcosa ossia quel momento di
distacco proprio dal pubblico in cui
un'idea comica nasce ci si lavora si
modifica e poi viene portata e questo è
un qualcosa di fondamentale non perché
faccia figo in generale dire che si
lavora ma perché c'è un momento di
gestazione anche di desiderio mancato di
incontrare il pubblico in cui ci si
Immagina che cosa sarà
e proprio A questo proposito ho portato
un un pezzo che incontra sia il teatro e
la comicità
è il pezzo del barista
è un pezzo che avevo in mente da tanto
tanto tempo e volevo riuscire a portare
su un palco quello che succede dentro un
bar e farlo vivere e questa sera grazie
al vuoto ossia Recitando da solo e
devocando tutti i personaggi che entrano
dentro un bar cercherò di farvi
immaginare e vivere una storia il vuoto
Non è un nemico a teatro è fondamentale
perché quello che si fa lo si fa per
fare immaginare nelle vostre teste come
primo sforzo immaginativo vi chiedo di
immaginare appunto che questo sia un
bancone del bar abbiamo dei potenti
mezzi scenografici
e siamo riusciti a farlo intanto
questo pezzo è stato scritto e la regia
l'ha fatta Gioele Dix di questo pezzo
per creare tutto quello che succede
dentro un bar abbiamo fatto un calco con
degli attori veri che entravano di qua
di là per capire quali sono i tempi
giusti per relazionarsi a una persona e
all'altra e quindi se funziona Voi
vedete il calco e dovreste immaginare
tutte le persone che entrano dentro
da un piccolo accenno sul barista sotto
casa mia è un tipo fenomenale adesso che
dove si può mettere anche idee or fuori
post pandemia si è allargato leggermente
ha messo i tavolini anche nella fermata
dell'autobus
però è tenerissimo perché lui ci tiene
un sacco fa anche da mangiare in una
maniera imbarazzante una tavola calda
però ci tiene alle recensioni
TripAdvisor Calcolate che lui adesso ha
una pallina e mezzo di media se la pena
superato la macchinetta che distribuisce
le merendine all'ospedale
però ci tiene e per darvi il tocco della
sua comicità di questo personaggio per
iniziarlo a immaginare a cominciare a
riempire questo vuoto
lui è fortissimo perché
vede gli chef stellati e vuole essere a
quel livello anche lui no quindi è
fortissimo perché ti dice Tipo allora di
dessert vi proponiamo un tris gelati che
facciamo noi c'è un gelato alla panna
con del latte di Malga che facciamo noi
vicino un gelato allo zabaione con delle
uova ruspanti che prendiamo noi e vicino
un gelato al cioccolato con delle fave
del Guatemala che andiamo a prendere noi
in mezzo a due cialde serigrafate Va
bene ok Rossella apporto un cucciolone
qua ai ragazzi che lo volevo questo per
disegnarvi chi è lui
va bene Vedo che le finezze non vi
sfuggono
questo personaggio si muoverà dentro
questo mondo immaginate che questo sia
il bancone del bar Là c'è l'ingresso la
c'è il bagno e la sinfonia faceva e fa
più o meno così
Rossella mi sa che abbiamo finito le
pastiglie della lavastoviglie si
Buongiorno dottore si subito si Roby la
gazzetta dovrebbe essere sul frigo
Rossella il tuo sfarciti diventano due
Eh no non si incazzi se freddo glielo
rifaccio subito Hobby Ma hai visto le
cose hai mangiato domenica
la scuola di mio figlio Io penso che
l'unico nero che non corre ce l'abbiamo
noi Pronto Sì le facciamo le ricariche
signora Timo Vodafone Sì sono io me la
passi Eh no signora Nokia la marca del
telefono sveglia su
pronto Salve maestra Sì signora prego è
libero in fondo a destra sì Eccomi
Rossella la chiave eh
ma doveva passarmi mia moglie a prendere
mio figlio No no no Abdul per cortesia
Non compriamo Niente
ho capito che piange io signora la luce
del bagno dove c'è scritto luce del
bagno grosso con la freccia
maestra Sì per cortesia mi passa Andrea
a signora attenta al gradino
ci godo
no se domenica non faccio altre punti ce
l'abbiamo Pronto Ciao Andre non piangere
tesoro Eh no Franco tramezzino solo
tonno non ce l'ho Cioè tonno e lattuga
Andre Stai tranquillo adesso risolviamo
Sì quella lievemente frizzante Nel frigo
vai prendila pure adesso risolviamo
tutto non ce l'ho Franco solo tonno c'è
tonno e lattuga ti ho detto sì Rossella
per cortesia mi devi la lattuga sto
cazzo di tramezzino perché sennò ammazzo
sto qua pronto Andre Sì papà deve
mettere giù che deve lavorare Sì
l'avviso io sì vedrai che arriva subito
la mammina Tenerina eh Bastarda
maledetta Eh no signora no a lei
Sì deve grattare con una moneta se
scontrerà banane uguali ha vinto
pronto stordita Eh ma non dovevi passare
tu a prendere Andrea sì Rossella un
altro macchiato caldo
Ma come sei in banca ma che Eh no
signora questo melone non è una banana e
non ha vinto un cazzo ma non lo so a
memoria il mio codice fiscale non so
micareimen Ciao bomber Eh no il bagno
occupato allora
jst mrz A proposito Rossella guarda un
po' se è morta quella lì dentro
79 hai scritto
No Coca light non ce l'ho c'ho la Zero
che è la stessa roba
di 969 J
quella Light per le femmine quella 0 per
i maschi
JJ come sta cippa sua Abbi pazienza Ben
tornata signora Eh Eravamo in pensiero
Complimenti per la fragranza Allora però
Pronto
Ho capito però sì tu adesso devi andare
Devi ho capito tu adesso devi non c'è
problema dottore segno tanto non
scappiamo di qua Sì ho capito che c'è la
coda non c'è problema buon lavoro Ciao
grande Ciao bello testa di cazzo quello
lì rara non paga mai Sì sì l'avviso io
la maestra sbrigati
Roby non ce la faccio più
se domenica mi dice di andare a mangiare
la sua mamma la denuncia te lo giuro eh
no signora pile non ne teniamo Mi
dispiace ce ne andiamo allo stadio e te
ce ne sbattiamo se Pronto Sì salve per
gentilezza mi passa la maestra Anna non
ho Abdul per cortesia Non compriamo
niente pronto Salve maestra Sì mia
moglie massimo un quarto d'ora gli Abdul
non lo voglio l'elefantino porta una
sfiga allucinante sta roba qua ho capito
che piange io
Rossella c'è il glutine nel Crodino ma
io che cosa ne so non so mica un biologo
Raga ho capito che deve andar via ma mia
moglie ha avuto un contrattempo
per cortesia vai a prendere mio figlio a
scuola un attimo corri sì vai di là sì
grande
sì
chiaro Sì maestra Certo sto risolvendo
tutto brillantemente Sì mi passa Andrea
Franchino Basta bere birra che sei
ubriaco marcio che è mezzogiorno pronto
Andre Ciao bello non passa la mamma eh
passa Abdul No Rossella basta birra
Franchino che se no finisce come l'altra
volta
ti fa tanti regalini cioè gli animalini
c'ha l'elefantino Cioè non vomitarmi qua
dentro vai via te Oh vai via
Ma non è vero che porta sfiga
l'elefantentino
è un simbolo di fertilità Passami la
maestra Rossella Passami la segatura che
ha combinato un casino quello lì pronto
Salve maestra Eh si passa Abdul è uno
zio quesito Sì Ciao bello Sì il bagno è
libero scavalchi Franchino Poi in fondo
a destra di là Sì devo mettere giù
maestra che devo avvisarmi mia moglie
Rossella dobbiamo fare qualcosa per il
marketing di questo bar
qui pisciano tutti non beve mai nessuno
pronto stordita Eh vai pure a farti le
unghie con ho risolto Scusami non ho I'm
sorry I can speak English with mean
Rossella via zanalli dove minchia è
Diglielo un attimo
assaggia a scuola Grazie non è tutta
dritta qua Ma che cazzo ne frega
strayton Cody su eBay Ah si è risolto
tutto
Ti amo tanto e lo so Tu sei la mia pera
pesca albicocca non Versace Sì ti amo
anch'io purghetta
Abdul Abbi pazienza È passata mia moglie
Sei un grande Grazie mille
Ti amo anch'io ci presto Sì tanto sì Eh
no sigarette non ne ho Guarda prova dal
tabacchino ma non ti assicuro niente
sì domenica andiamo a mangiare a tua
mamma va bene si fa Va bene
Sì sì scusa un attimo
Abdul Ma chi cazzo è sto bambino
Grazie mille
grazie mille grazie mille
[Applauso]